And speaking of VSEPR, that's
what we did last lecture.
We're going to move on today.
But I want to just clarify
something about VSEPR.
When I was talking
about this I tried
to put two different
concepts in the same place.
And I put something in the table
that shouldn't have been there.
And people corrected me.
I want to be sure that there
is no confusion around this.
So what we had was a
case of formaldehyde.
And we had the case of SO2.
And I want to be really
clear about this.
Both of these
molecules, when you're
thinking about VSEPR, the number
of electron domain count--
Right.
Remember, that's how we start.
The number of electron domains
is the same for both of them.
And we did this on Wednesday.
Right.
And if the number of
electron domains is the same,
then the electron domain
geometry is trigonal planar.
Right.
OK.
But I was also telling
you about repulsion order
at the same time.
And so I put the wrong
thing in the table.
And then I erased it.
And I just want to
be sure we're clear
and we don't get bent
out of shape about it.
[LAUGHTER]
Stop.
[CLAPPING]
Get out of here.
Stop.
Stop it.
All right.
I'm going to still be here.
I'm going to be here.
All right.
So like here, right, the shape.
Remember, what the
table was about
was the number of lone pairs.
OK.
The number of lone pairs.
And so if I've got
the three binding
pairs and no lone
pairs, then it's
going to be a
trigonal planar shape.
So that is trigonal planar.
And over here I've
got two bonding pairs
and one lone pair.
And so this shape
is called bent.
Now, what I did is
I used that word.
Aw, why?
I don't know.
But you make mistakes.
When you're in the
arena, you keep going.
And if you make a
mistake, you admit it.
You leave it all there.
You do your best.
Forget the rest.
That's all you can ever do.
Now, here's the thing.
I said bent.
I said the word bent.
And what I was
talking about was how
that bends a little bit
because of the repulsion order.
Yeah.
But that shape is not bent.
I want to be real
clear about that.
That shape is trigonal planer.
And it's a little bit distorted.
OK.
This shape is bent.
That shape is bent, because
it's got a lone pair.
Remember, the shape is
about where the atoms are.
But it's also a
little bit distorted.
Right?
Because the lone pair pushes on
those guys a little bit more.
All right.
OK.
So those are the two concepts
that I was saying all at once.
And I want to make sure
we understand them.
There's trigonal planar.
there's bent.
And then there's
repulsion order,
which talks about little changes
in the angle from those parent
shapes.
OK.
Good.
All right.
Now, onto today.
Now, here's the thing.
Now, in all of this
stuff with Lewis,
it's a really good way
to think about molecules.
But this tells me that
there's electrons on the bond.
It tells me that
there's electrons
really localized in the
region between the atoms.
But see, the thing is,
how much is it localized?
How much is it really?
Are these electrons-- if I were
to draw the two electrons, are
those dots right there?
It doesn't really tell me
more information than that.
But if we remember the picture--
let's see if I can pull.
Yep.
There it is.
There's a picture I
showed you when we first
talked about covalent bonds.
Sharing is caring.
Remember what happens.
I've got the two protons.
And we talked about these.
A repulsion.
And then the two electrons.
Repulsion.
And then I drew for
you the fact that,
but they can come together.
And they can be
like, you know what?
You can use my proton for a
little of your attraction.
And hey, can I use your--
And they share it.
And each electron
sees both of them.
And this is where
those electrons are.
But look at that.
The proton is there and there.
And the electron is in
this probability cloud
around both of them.
That's the molecular orbital.
And Lewis can't
tell us about that.
So we need something else.
And that's what
today's topic is about.
Today we're going to talk
about something called
molecular orbital theory
that gives us a sense of how
these atomic orbitals overlap.
It gives us a much better
and a deeper description
with more details about
these covalent bonds.
OK.
All right.
Now, so let's write a few things
about molecular orbital theory.
Molecular orbital.
And what we're going to do is
say, MO, and Molecular Orbital
theory.
So we'll keep a list of
some important things.
All right.
Well, first of all,
the first thing
is that atomic orbitals,
or, as we may call them,
AOs, are the basis for--
watch this efficiency, the MOs.
I didn't have to write it again.
Right?
OK.
So what does that mean?
Well, it means that I'm going to
construct the MOs from the AOs.
Now, the AOs are
the things we've
been playing with and making.
Right?
We solved the
Schrodinger equation.
So the MOs are going to
be linear combinations.
All right.
Combinations of the AOs.
And that's why you might
see this, in fact, called
LCAO theory.
LCAO.
Linear Combination
of Atomic Orbitals.
OK.
And in particular, sum
and difference of orbitals
is what we're about.
Because this is like what
we talked about before.
These are waves.
Right.
Waves can either constructively
or destructively interfere.
And that's what we're going
to explore in MO theory.
By adding or subtracting
these wave functions,
these orbitals, these
atomic orbitals.
So that's enough to start.
Let's see.
So look, basis.
A basis is nothing
more than the things
that I'm going to use to
represent the things that I
want.
Right.
And the things that I want
are these molecular orbitals.
And the things that I'm going
to use to represent those
are these, these
beautiful atomic orbitals
that we spent a lot of time
understanding and developing.
We'll start with the
simplest case, which is--
I think I have--
oh, I even highlighted it.
And I said, let's first
make molecular orbitals
using combinations
of the S orbital.
That's the S orbital.
That's the 1s orbital up there.
Remember, by the
way, blue and orange
is just the sign of the wave.
Right.
This is not a charge.
Please don't make
that confusion.
These are just waves.
Right.
Waves.
And let's go back and see it.
The p orbital has
a plus and a minus.
It's a wave.
All right.
And the 2s orbital has that too.
And then you square it, and
you get the probabilities.
Right?
OK.
So we'll start with 1s where
it's all just one sign.
And I can add it.
I can add an S and another
S. Or I can subtract it.
So let's do that.
Right.
So we'll do that over here.
All right.
So if I take a 1s orbital, and
I add it to another 1s orbital,
well, you can see, as I
bring these close together,
if they have the same
sign, these are waves.
So if the waves
are both positive,
and I bring them together, they
can constructively interfere.
So as I bring them
closer and closer,
well, I might actually
get the picture
that I showed you, right?
I might actually get something
that looks like this.
OK.
I might actually get
something like this.
Now, if I subtracted them,
then as I bring these orbitals
closer together, well, they're
going to cancel each other.
And you can see right here,
if I bring these orbitals--
by the way, which are coming
from two different atoms.
Right.
The whole point is we're talking
about molecules, molecular.
So if I bring them
together now like this,
but I'm subtracting
these orbitals,
then you can see that right
at the interface, right
between them, it's always zero.
Because I've just
subtracted the same amount.
No matter how close
they get, it's zero.
That's a node.
Right.
And, in fact, what
you're going to get
is something that
looks like this.
Now, so what I've done is
I have added and subtracted
the same AO.
And I've created two MOs.
So these are my MOs.
And these are my starting AOs.
That's about the simplest
thing you can do in MO theory.
So I'm using these as a basis.
Now, there's something very
important, which is that--
I kind of already
alluded to this--
these are two atoms coming
together to make a bond.
This is the bonding axis.
OK.
Now, if an orbital,
if an MO is symmetric,
so if it has cylindrical
symmetry about that bonding
axis, then it's called
a sigma orbital.
It's called a sigma orbital.
That's the MO.
Sigma is a notation.
A sigma orbital is
one that has symmetry
around the internuclear
axis, the two--
Does Pauli exclusion
not apply to that?
We're coming to that very soon.
Because these are
just the orbitals.
I got to do something with them.
It's just like over here.
I made all these orbitals.
But then I had to fill them.
That got me excited.
But you can see right here.
When I add them up
there's charge in between.
So this looks like it's
going to have a bond.
That's a bonding MO.
But if I subtracted them,
this doesn't look very happy
in terms of electrons
being in between
and the caring is sharing
principle of a covalent bond.
Right.
So if I were to put an
electron in this MO,
it doesn't look bonding.
In fact, it looks--
Non-bonding.
Or antibonding.
It's actually not
quite non-binding.
We'll get to that later.
This would be antibonding.
Why?
Because there's not even
a chance of electron
density in between.
That's your starting
principle of the relationship.
Let's try to share.
Oh, by the way, right
half way, no chance.
That's not a very
good way to start.
And you can see why
this is antibonding.
It's the opposite.
You're actually pushing
charge away from the bond
if you're an electron
in that orbital.
So that's an
antibonding orbital.
Now we get to the question.
What do you do with
these orbitals?
Well, you make them.
I made these with 1s.
And the way that we
typically draw this is we
go back to the same
picture that we've
been working with,
1s here and 1s here.
And I brought those
orbitals together,
and I formed one that lowered
the energy of the system,
and another that actually
raised the energy of the system,
because the electrons
are repelling.
They're actually less bonding.
They're antibonding.
All right.
So these are my MOs.
Those are my AOs.
Right.
AO, AO.
And now, this is
called a sigma orbital.
And the way we refer to
the antibonding orbital
is with a little star.
They're both sigma because
they both satisfy that.
Right.
They're both sigma
cause they both have
symmetry around the inter
nuclear bonding axis.
But now, see, OK.
So that's good.
But now let's fill them.
Let's fill them.
Because now let's
write down the rules.
And then we'll fill
them for some examples.
OK.
So I'm going to keep going
on my MO theory list.
Right.
As you can see, when I do it
this way, the number of MOs
equals the number of
AOs used to create them.
So that's one thing that
we can see right away.
Right.
I used two AOs.
I added and subtracted them.
I got two MOs.
That's good.
Well, another thing is, each
MO will be just like an AO.
It makes a lot of sense.
I had room for two
electrons here.
I got to have room for four.
Two here.
Right.
So each MO has a max
of two electrons.
And they must obey
Pauli, just like in AOs.
They must obey Pauli.
You can't mess with
quantum mechanics.
Uh-uh.
They're still electrons.
They're still
quantum mechanical.
All right.
You're just making their wave
function more sophisticated.
But they still have to
follow the Schrodinger
equation and the principles
of quantum mechanics.
And so, finally, what
we're going to do
is we're going to fill them.
So we're going to fill the
MOs with electrons, starting
with the lowest energy,
just like we did
for atoms, lowest energy first.
OK.
And one more thing.
Just like we did with atoms
is we're going to obey Hund.
Hund.
Hund's rule, which
tells you about how
to fill degenerate orbitals.
Well, we're going to have
degenerate orbitals here too.
We don't yet.
But we will.
So we're going to fill them.
So let's fill them for
the very simplest cases.
OK.
So we'll do some cases together.
And we'll see how that goes.
All right.
So what I'm going to do are four
cases just so we can compare.
So first, we're
going to do H2 plus.
OK.
That's the first one.
And here, what we have
is the same graph.
But now, over here I
actually can label it now.
This was just an orbital.
But now, gazuntite.
Now, I'll say, OK.
Well, this would be
like H and H plus.
OK.
These are my MOs, sigma,
sigma star, 1s, 1s.
Oh, boy.
So if that's H
and that's H plus,
and they're coming together
to make H2 plus-- that's
what's in the middle there.
That's the molecule.
All right.
Well, then I also can now
fill in the starting AOs.
So let's do that.
That's it.
Because somebody had to lose
an electron to start with.
So now, when these come
together, you fill.
You obey the Pauli exclusion.
You fill it from the
lowest energy first.
You say, well, I only
got one electron.
There it is.
That's my MO diagram
populated by electrons.
OK.
Now, there's a principle
that comes out of this.
There's a way of understanding
bond strength now.
There's a way of
understanding bond strength.
And that is a very
important concept.
Now, let's put it
here in our list.
OK.
And it's a concept
called bond order.
Now, this one I really
want to write BO.
But I don't know if
that's a good idea.
I got Laura on that one.
OK.
And there's a
definition for this.
It's going to equal 1/2
of the number of electrons
in a bonding orbital, minus
the number of electrons
in an antibonding orbital.
Sorry.
This is a little bit small here.
But we'll do a bunch of them
so you can see what this means.
Right.
So now, the bond order is
important because the bond
order of a molecule, if it's
higher than a stronger bond,
and it has to be greater
than zero for stability.
Let's see how that works.
And we'll see this intuitively
as well as we fill these up.
Right.
So if I count the bond order
here-- oh, I'm going to do it.
I don't feel like
writing it out.
The BO on this one is 1/2 times
1 minus 0, which equals 1/2.
OK.
Good.
It's 1/2.
Well, it's greater than 0.
So right away I know that the
H2 plus molecule is probably
stable.
That's good.
But let's go to some
more examples now.
Let's do a few more.
All right.
Now we're going to
work our way to H2.
And in this case,
energy is always
going up in these diagrams.
Now, each of these H atoms
is bringing an electron.
There's no charge to the system.
And so now different
quantum numbers.
Pauli.
But same sigma.
Right.
And so now that's the H2.
Now, the bond order
here is equal to 1.
Right?
I didn't have any electrons
in an antibonding orbital.
All right.
But you know what's coming.
I'm going to do He2 plus next.
And let's just put it here
for comparison in real time.
If I were He2, each of these
would be the AO occupation
of an He atom.
Right?
But since I'm He2 plus, one of
them is missing an electron.
So this is what
you're going to see.
These are both He atoms
still, but one of them
is plus in this picture.
But see now, OK.
I've got three electrons.
They're going to go here.
And I've got to put one up here.
I have to.
Cause I had three.
I got to keep on filling,
just like in an atom.
But now I'm filling bonding
and antibonding orbitals.
All right.
And here I've got
this and two up there.
So if you look at
the bond order,
here the bond order
is still positive.
Here the bond order is zero.
And, in fact, that's why He2
is not a stable molecule.
Because you're putting just as
much charge on this thing that
wants to bond it as
you are on this thing
that doesn't want to bond it.
And at the end of the day,
it leads to a molecule
that is not stable.
So that would be He2.
But He2 plus has a bond
order that's similar.
Did I get something wrong?
He2 plus 1/2.
OK.
Now, because this weakened it.
Right.
This weakened the
molecule, compared
to this, because
now I added charge
to an antibonding orbital.
So you would expect
from the bond order
that this one is more
stable than this.
And, in fact, that's
what you find.
Right.
The H2 molecule has a
stronger bonding energy.
Now, we can write the molecular
orbital configurations
just like we did with the
atomic orbital configurations.
OK.
And so like for here,
so for this case--
I'm going to write it
up top if I can fit it.
So here we would have sigma 1s.
And we're populating it with--
Ah.
That's not my example.
[GRUNTING]
This is my example.
Sigma 1s is the orbital.
And we're populating
it with one electron.
Right.
So that's how we
would write that.
Now, if we go to
the next examples,
we would have this one
is this molecule you
would write as sigma 1s 2.
So this would be sigma 1s 2.
And oh, now I've got sigma 1s 2.
Oh, this is getting interesting.
Because now it's
sigma star 1s 1.
So everybody see that?
I populate.
This is just like SPD.
But now I'm just
filling those MOs up.
And I'm showing you what
the molecular configuration
is with those molecular
orbital names.
Sigma 1s.
Sigma 1s star.
OK.
Good.
Now, we can keep going.
We could do this all day.
Actually, we kind of will.
But we're going to move on--
don't worry-- from sigma.
Let's see.
Let me go over here.
There's another
concept that I want
you to know about MO theory.
So if I kept going, I could
have, for example, let's
do lithium.
OK.
So now, lithium 1s.
Oh-ho.
2s.
Lithium brings this.
What does it bring?
It brings three electrons.
And over here, 1s and
2s, three electrons.
So this would be
the lithium dimer.
But I want to make
an important point.
When you would draw this one,
here's how I would draw it.
Whereas when I would draw this
one, I would draw it like this.
OK.
Now, those are supposed
to be the same spacing.
I'll tell you in a second.
Notice that the distance
here between the bonding
and antibonding orbital
is larger than it is here.
The reason is because it's
related to the overlap.
So there's another point, which
is that the overlap of AOs
is related.
So the greater the
overlap of AOs,
the greater the change in energy
between bonding and antibonding
orbitals.
And let's be clear.
Those are molecular.
But see, you could see
like, if I'm lithium,
those 1ses aren't going
to overlap too much.
Right.
They're kind of
close to the core.
So you do get MOs there.
But the difference
that you get depends
on how much these electrons are
near in energy and overlapping.
All right.
So the 2s can
overlap a lot more.
OK.
Now, if I were to
fill this up, we
would get something like this.
These sigma 1ses-- oh, sigma 1s.
What do you think
these are called?
2s.
Sigma 2s.
OK.
This is getting a little bit--
I'm going to draw this out here.
That's the sigma 1s star.
Right.
And this would be
the sigma 2s star.
Well, what am I going to occupy?
Well, how many electrons
do I have to pour
into the molecular orbitals?
[GRUNTING]
Lithium 2 is stable, because
its bond order is-- you see.
Bond order.
Number of electrons
in bonding orbitals,
one, two, three,
four, minus the number
of electrons in antibonding,
minus 1, 2, divided by 2.
So the lithium dimer
bonding order is 1.
All right.
And then you can go
on, and you could say,
well, if I had beryllium, I'd
have another electron here
and here.
And I'd fill those
antibonding orbitals up again,
like in the He2 dimer.
And I would have, again,
an unstable molecule,
which is, in fact, true.
OK.
This is sort of the
simplest way you
can think about
molecular orbital theory
because it's the
simplest orbital.
But you could spend
the whole night.
And it is a Friday.
What else do you have--
this is what you do on a Friday.
After I watch Dr.
Quantum I'm going
to just add every single one
of these with every single one.
It's finite.
It's not going to take forever.
Let's just do p.
OK.
Now, with p orbitals there's
something interesting that
happens, because now that sign--
you see how the p has
a plus and a minus?
Right.
And so you've got to kind of
think about that a little bit.
OK.
If I take a p orbital, and
I'm going to do it like this.
Minus, plus.
And I'm going to add it to a p
orbital that looks like this.
And notice, I'm
taking these and I'm
adding them along an
axis where they're
kind of both along the axis.
Right.
They're both along the axis.
And by convention, we'll do the
pz as the one along the axis.
Remember, there's
px, py, and pz.
When we solve for
the p orbitals,
those are the Ms. Those
are the Ms. Right.
One.
Zero.
And minus 1.
Now, by convention we put the
pz along the bonding axis.
And you can see right
away, so if I do this,
well, I'm going to
start adding these wave
functions constructively.
And what you're
going to get is--
let's see if I can draw this--
something that looks like that.
And where this is
actually going to be plus.
And this is minus.
And notice that I'm going
to have nodes in there.
Right.
I had nodes in the
original orbitals.
But I got a lot of
bonding in between.
I got a lot of bonding
density in between.
That is a bonding orbital.
And the other thing
we see about this
is that it is symmetric
around that bonding axis.
So it's actually a
sigma pz orbital.
It's a sigma.
We call it a sigma, because it's
symmetric around the bonding
axis.
Now, if I were to take a px--
oh, well, let's
actually subtract these.
OK.
So minus, plus, minus.
Now, what you see is something
very different, right.
So now, oh, boy.
Can I draw this?
Maybe.
I don't know.
OK.
I'll take that.
Right.
And so now what you see--
so I'm subtracting these.
And so the density goes down.
And now, you're going
to get minus, minus.
Right.
Plus, plus.
But I've reduced the
electron density.
And even worse, I'm
back to that situation
where right in between where
I want to share the most,
I'm saying no.
No probability density there.
And that's an antibonding
sigma p orbital.
So this would be sigma star pz.
OK.
Sigma star pz.
Now, the other thing
that you can do
is look at the other directions.
Right.
And so I'll just take one
of those really quick.
And if you do that, you
see something different.
All right.
So now, let's combine
these like this.
By the way, some textbooks.
We're adding and subtracting.
We're constructively interfering
and destructively interfering.
So sometimes you'll see
a textbook add like this,
or add the other way, which
is subtracting like this.
But it's the same thing.
Right?
You can decide how
you want to orient it.
But we're adding and
subtracting constructively
and destructively.
That's what we're doing.
So I'm going to choose
to add it like this.
Because then you just
see, if I do this,
then those are going to
have some kind of overlap.
Right.
Those are going to have
some overlap of plus
appear and some overlap
of minus down there.
And that is called,
oh, a pi orbital.
Yeah.
But if I subtracted them,
then what you would see
is something that looks
more like this, where you
got that node in between again.
Right.
And this would be
a pi star orbital.
This would be for
like px orbitals.
Now, notice, these
cannot be sigmas,
because the pi orbital is not
symmetric around the bonding
axis.
OK.
These cannot be sigmas.
But that's why we have
another symbol for them.
Luckily, we've got
a lot of symbols,
and the chemists are
geniuses at naming things.
And so these are
called pi orbitals.
And as you can see, OK.
I have three orbitals.
One, I put it along the axis.
And then I've got two
going perpendicular
in the other plane.
And this is one of them.
And then the other one
would be the other one, py.
So as you can see, I'm going
to have a sigma star, two pi
orbitals, and two
pi star orbitals.
Right.
And then what we got to
do is we got to put them
on our energy scale.
And instead of going
through drawing it all,
I'll save myself a
few minutes here.
I'll show it to you.
All right.
So there is that energy scale.
And oh, they're
pointing out the nodes.
Isn't that beautiful?
You can see right here.
They're not saying what
molecule this is yet.
This is a 2p orbital.
And it's pointing along the
same bond axis as the other one.
So this is going to
be a sigma p orbital.
This is a sigma p orbital.
And you can see that.
And there's a sigma star.
Right.
Good.
Now, if we go to that,
there's the next one.
There's a pi orbital.
And you get the
same exact effect.
You've got a lowering
of the energy,
cause you're putting
electrons on the bond,
and a raising of the energy
cause you're taking them away.
Right.
And that's what it looks
like for the pi orbital.
And we can put it all together.
And if you put it all
together, what I want to do
is put it together for O2
and then show you a video,
and then do my why this matters.
Now, if you put
this together, I'm
going to show you the system
for oxygen and nitrogen. OK.
And then we'll do a
couple other cases too.
But we're going to
do oxygen first.
So if I take oxygen,
then I'm not even
going to write 1s anymore.
That's way down in energy.
It's not really
involved in the bonding.
I'm going to leave it out.
But I've got my
oxygen 1s, oxygen 1s.
OK.
Good.
So those are going to come in
and form molecular orbitals
like that.
And we know that
they are all filled.
OK.
Now, up here I've
got my oxygen. Sorry.
I just said I wasn't
going to do 1s.
And I'm not.
Those are 2s.
Sigma 2s.
Sigma star 2s.
OK.
Good.
All right.
Oh.
Let's see.
Now, over here, I
start with my ps.
And I start with px, py, pz.
And in oxygen, how many
electrons do I have in here?
So it's like this.
[INAUDIBLE]
Everybody should be shouting.
[SIGHS]
That's so much better.
That was close.
And then I've got to-- well, I'm
not going to have enough room.
I've got these over here.
px, py, pz.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
And there is oxygen.
But you see, now,
they come together.
And they form these MOs.
And we just went over
what types they are.
Right.
There's a sigma pz orbital.
And there's a sigma
M. But the ordering
is about the same
thing that we learned,
which is that it has to do--
this delta is up there.
This delta is up there.
And so in that pz for
oxygen, you can overlap more.
It pushes those apart more.
And so what you get is that
the pis are inside like that.
The pis are inside.
Right.
So if I write in here, it's
going to get too small.
So I'm going to do this.
This would be a sigma 2pz.
This would be a sigma 2pz star.
And over here, these
would be pi orbitals.
Pi px, pi py.
And these almost can fit
pi star px and pi star py.
All looking like the shapes
that we've been drawing.
Right.
And then the filling part comes
from the filling of the AOs.
Right.
I've got my filling
of the AOs here.
I've got the valence
filling for oxygen.
There is a 1s down there.
Right.
And so I've got to put
four electrons from there
and four electrons from
here into the middle.
So let's do that.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
Pauli.
Right.
So for oxygen, the bond
order, if you add it up,
the BO is two.
It's a double bond.
We know that.
Oh, but now we
know so much more.
And this is what I
want to make a point.
Lewis could have gotten us this.
But Lewis can't
get us magnetism.
Lewis can't get us magnetism.
Molecular orbital theory can.
OK.
And let me show you
magnetism right up close.
Because if I take liquid
nitrogen. That's not me though.
And I pour it through
a huge magnet.
I want that magnet so badly.
But if I did that, look at that.
Liquid nitrogen just
goes right on through.
And it's really
fun to do actually.
But there you go.
That's liquid nitrogen.
But look at liquid
oxygen. Liquid oxygen. Now
you pour it through, and the
magnet holds it in place.
All right.
Whoa is right.
There's four more things
we've got to cover.
One is paramagnetism.
Another is something
called mixing.
Another is what happens
when you go hetero nuclear.
Oh, yeah.
You'll see what that
means in a second.
And finally, what I
said I would get to,
which is non-bonding, which are
not the same as antibonding.
What I'm covering right now,
there, is paramagnetism.
Because as you saw on the
exam in one of the questions,
we explained it.
We said if you got unpaired
electrons, then you are--
what does paramagnetism mean?
It means that if you put a huge
magnet on it, you'll respond.
You will feel a force
from that magnetic field.
And so we did that in the exam.
We had a silicon atom, because
we hadn't done molecules.
But now we got molecules.
So I can tell you why
that experiment happened.
What's happening?
I can tell you why that
experiment happens.
Really?
I didn't even know
there was more.
[LAUGHTER]
It happens because of Hund's
rule, molecular orbitals,
and the fact that I've got
these two unpaired electrons
in the O2 molecule.
And you know that in nitrogen
those two electrons are gone,
cause nitrogen is missing
one more here and here.
So you've got two less.
Everything's filled.
Paramagnetism.
Now, OK.
Speaking of magnetism,
I couldn't help but show
you this.
This is diamagnetism.
Now, diamagnetism,
everything is filled.
But you still feel a little
repulsion to a magnetic field.
And some of you may know there
is this thing called the Ig
Noble Prize.
Only one person
in history has won
both the Ig Noble
and the Nobel Prize,
Andre Geim who discovered
graphene with scotch tape.
But before that he
won the Ig Noble Prize
because he did this to frogs.
Because water is diamagnetic.
And so it repels
a magnetic field.
It's just got to be really,
really, really high.
I hope that frog was OK.
It looked sort of OK.
So the frog was floating.
And it was like a study about
levitation using magnetism.
Why am I showing that to you?
No particular reason.
[LAUGHTER]
But this does get me to
the why this matters,
which has to do with
how you cook pasta.
And, of course, since
we're talking about O2,
when I have finished
cooking pasta, what do I do?
I pour it.
There it is.
It's like it's sophisticated.
I pour it through a colander.
That's a membrane.
You did use a membrane.
You did a filter.
Now, but I could also
have done that separation,
that same separation, I could
have left it on the stove.
I could have.
And it would have
boiled out all the water
and left me still with the
pasta separated from the water.
I've accomplished
the same exact thing.
I have separated the
pasta from the water.
Test done.
Pasta may not taste as good.
[LAUGHTER]
But you've done it.
But see, the thing is that if
you separate things this way
versus that way, you can just
feel how much less energy
it's going to take.
In fact, you can save
over 80% of the energy
if you do a membrane
based separation
as opposed to a thermal one.
Gazuntite.
So those are two ways
to separate pasta.
But see, there's two ways
to separate lots of things.
Like how about 1 to 10
nanometer particles?
How about chemistry?
How about molecules?
How do you separate those?
Well, you got the same two ways.
And if you count up all the
things we separate this way,
it's a lot.
It goes on and on.
And it will go all the way
down the Infinite Corridor.
And this is how we do chemistry.
In fact, has anyone seen
this on the side of the road?
That's a distillation column.
It's a big pasta cooker.
That's all you're doing is
boiling one molecule off
of another over a long time
with a whole lot of fossil fuel.
In fact, if you look at
the US energy consumption,
roughly a third of it
goes into industry.
40% of that is for
this one thing.
It's boiling pasta.
But the pasta is 1 nanometer
to 10 nanometer particles.
40% goes into boiling
one chemical species off
of another.
Separation.
That's 12% of all the energy.
That's the same as
every single drop
of gasoline in every
single car truck and bus.
Just to give you a sense
of how much energy that is.
You'll say, well, why
aren't we using a colander?
Why don't we just pour
it through a colander
like we do our boiling pasta?
Well, we do that for one field.
Desalination.
I got a [INAUDIBLE]
on that another time.
But we don't do it for
all those other things.
And there's a really
simple reason.
We don't have the
right pasta colander.
We don't.
There's no option
for that size scale
that can withstand the
conditions that are in all
of those chemical separations.
But if we did--
we take so much
O2 out of the air.
We need O2.
But we don't want the N2.
So we have to separate it.
How do we do it?
We go cryogenic.
We go to very, very
cold temperatures,
which is the same as boiling.
Right.
But you're still spending
all this fossil fuel
to lower the temperature.
That's how much O2 we
generate each year.
And this is how much
energy it takes.
It's like 1/2 a percent of
all US energy, just to get--
But what if you
could use something
like O2's paramagnetism?
What if you could use something
about the chemistry or O2
to do this separation
more efficiently,
lower energy, or maybe make a
new colander that does that?
And if any of you have
ideas, come talk to me.
This is a problem
I care a lot about.
OK.
Ah.
But I had some
other-- paramagnetism.
Unpaired electrons.
We got that one.
Ha.
[SIGHS]
Why is chemistry not--
why can't they follow the rules?
Why?
But they always
got to break them.
And what we see, this
was oxygen. Sigma.
Sigma S. Sigma.
Sigma star.
Pi.
Pi star.
But look at what happens
for nitrogen. Why?
Because of something some
people like to call mixing.
Remember, I said that--
where did it-- somewhere I
said that the closer in energy,
or the closer in
symmetry orbitals are,
the more overlap they can
have, and the more they
interact and can mix
together in the ways
that I've been talking about.
Yeah.
Well, it turns out that if
you go below oxygen, in what
are called homonuclear dimers,
which is where the atoms are
the same, then you
can get mixing even
between this sigma
and that sigma.
And so what happens
is, instead of them
being kind of separate
like this for N2,
there is an interaction.
You see.
You can think about
it the same way.
I'm throwing more
orbitals into the mix.
And so because they can
contribute to overlapping,
you're changing that
delta E even more.
That's effectively
what's happening.
And so you can see this
one for nitrogen goes down,
but that one goes up.
Because that's the delta E.
Because it's able to mix in.
It's able to mix in because
they have the same symmetry.
And they're closer.
For those smaller atoms,
they're a lot closer in energy.
And so if you look at this,
what happens is those switch.
They switch.
It's real.
Now, it doesn't change the
thing I just talked about,
which is the magnetic
properties of N2,
because they are
still all filled.
But it is important.
Because if I were to pull
an electron out of N2,
it would come from a sigma
orbital, not a pi orbital,
because of those interactions.
And those happen below O2.
So this is from your textbook.
And you see, it says
2s 2pz interaction.
Remember, 2pz is sigma.
Sigma.
Same symmetry.
Able to mix.
Don't mix very well here.
But here they're
strong enough to change
the ordering of that
orbital and that orbital.
Right.
You see that?
That's an important effect.
OK.
All right.
But it only happens below O2.
It happens below
O2, because that's
where those energies
and orbitals can line up
in that way.
OK.
So we just covered that.
Now, there's two more things.
And then that's
all of MO theory.
One is I've been giving
you the same atoms.
But what if we go from
a homonuclear dimer
to a heteronuclear dimer, which
just means one is one and one
is another type of atom.
How do we draw an
MO diagram for that?
And the second thing
is what happens?
The second thing is what
happens in this case?
In HCl, H is bringing only
one S electron to the party.
But Cl is bringing
all of the-- it's
bringing S. It's bringing
P. What does it do?
Right.
How does the MO diagram
look in that case, where
I've got all these
extra electrons coming
in from one of the atoms.
Now, I will not do
this in 30 seconds.
But I will, next week,
give you a nice sort
of thorough explanation for
each of these two last MO cases.
In the meantime, have
a very good weekend.